tell me did you think Batman vs Superman
the epical addition she okay so am i
remember back in 2000-2001 when batman v
superman first got announced as being a
movie that was in pre-production it got
canceled they got movie posters and i am
legend 2 got loads of stuff i waited all
that time and it finally got released in
the start of this year and if you like
me you are very disappointed when you
seen it now to address this warner
brothers have released an extended
edition of the movie called the ultimate
cut or ever and let's just say it vastly
improves at the a trickle cut I thought
the theatrical cut was pretty [ __ ] I am
coming out of it I was like alright with
it but the more I thought about was like
this doesn't make sense that doesn't
make sense that's a stupid motive and
and it has really improved on that it's
kind of like when you tell a joke and if
you miss out like bits in the joke the
punchline is still going to be the same
but it might not be as funny the job
might not make sense and this is kind of
what I think Batman V Superman sup
suffered from so now it's had all the
contexts added to it and it is a lot
better movie it feels a lot for that a
lot of them motives makes sense now like
at the start they have an extended part
where Superman saves Louis and
originally I was like well why would
people think Superman killed all those
villages because like they were shot and
they explained in this movie what
happened in it there is just a little
bit like that it makes sense more why
Superman hate Batman because Henry
Cavill gets a lot more screen time in
the original cut he had like eight lines
and it was his movie and in this one is
really being fleshed out you get a lot
more of the clock and report aside with
helps fill in why he dislikes Batman
because he's hearing these stories from
people and he's like yo this Batman
guy's a proper [ __ ] I have just seen
the movie and I've just come away from
watching it it's not perfect it still
has its problems I would probably say
it's as good as dark knight rises maybe
a bit worse maybe a bit better depending
on what kind of person you are
personally I think it's that kind of
level it has lots of plot holes still in
it I'd say from the original theatrical
cut about 75% of the plot holes have
been improved upon and now the first
part of the movie which is all the setup
is where you get the extended scenes in
but from about the Batman vs Superman
fight onwards so that's the the fight
and then it's the factory bit where
Batman saves Martha and the Doomsday
fight and the epilogue it's all pretty
much the same movies you saw on the
cinema however it's the setup it's the
investigations that and Clark Kent does
it's like they're the back story really
like I said before you need this stuff
it's like a joke you need the good setup
to make everything makes sense and this
does really flesh out the movie and I'm
trying to think kind of what was
extended and so there was a bit with
Jimmy Olsen's introduced I still don't
think they should have killed him off
but it is a bit better there's a lot of
the court hearings there in the picture
there more prominent there a lot better
as well and the Batman scenes are pretty
much all the same there's not that much
difference it's like a couple of extra
dialogue changes and this talks like
Arkham it's just fleshing out the
backstory you do see kind of see the
divide between metropolis and Gotham and
but most of Batman's backstories kind of
told through Superman's investigation
like it goes to see people and they they
explain like how Batman's got worse
and so this adds more scenes for Clark
Kent nepean and it also adds depth to
Batman's character because obviously was
the character who was introduced in this
movie and obviously people are familiar
with Batman but they're not so familiar
with like this world's this universe as
Batman and but yeah really really
enjoyed it and I wouldn't yeah I didn't
really like the theatrical cut this much
I think this one's a lot more watchable
and it does annoy me because I wish that
studios will just give people like the
chance to make the movie they want to
make obviously I know they want to have
there's a certain amount of cinema that
movie has to be a certain length for you
to get certain amount of showings in a
day and you can make the most profit
from that so you movies have to be about
two hours 30 max to kind of get the most
money they can generate from it and but
I just wish they hadn't occurred some of
this stuff in the movie it was vital
information the bullet plot that Louis
has is in the theatrical cut it was so
confused and you didn't really get was
what was going on why the bullet mad
this time around that really fleshed out
and you really get it you get why alexis
Lex Luthor in the theatrical cut was
like always a [ __ ] villain and just
don't understand why he's doing this he
just seems crazy and in this they flesh
out why he's doing it why he's
manipulating people and you actually see
a lot more of his manipulations in the
original cut you didn't see how he
manipulated Superman in a hate and
Batman and he does this time and I just
don't understand why they cut this movie
The Nightmare scene it's great a look at
really good scene but that adds
absolutely nothing in the movie if you
were going to cut something they should
have cut the nightmare sequence and put
in the the dialogue scenes that add
context to the movie and it would have
just made a lot more sense and I think a
lot of people would had less problems
with the movie and it probably would
have made more money
em I know the theatrical cuts pretty
much you come by anywhere now and it's
always like the ultimate cut I see
listed on amazon ebay everywhere like
that and so yeah they're kind of like
sweeping that under the rug be like yo
we never made this this is the ultimate
cut the cut we meant for you to see so i
do i really like zack snyder as a
director I mean I love doing the dead I
think three hundreds really good like as
a action movie watch men I think's
fantastic I think it's one of the most
underrated comic book movies of all time
and because of the extended cut because
of how good that extended cut is and
batman v superman is probably going to
rank up there and irie disliked it I
thought I was like get Zack Snyder off
Justice League is a dick at I hate them
because i'm fickle like that and I'll
turn on anyone a second um and yeah
there's I think if they give him what he
wants to do with justice league it'll be
a good movie whereas if they do what
they did with Batman V Superman which is
cut stuff it's not going to be good it
is a very dark movie still there's not
jokes inserted it's the tone is it isn't
any lighter so if you didn't like the
tone you prefer like Marvel like jokes
in between fights like goofy stuff not
that there's anything wrong with that
and I just prefer a darker tone I feel
like this movie delivered more on that
and so yeah really really quite happy
with it definitely buy on blu-ray if you
were let down by Batman V Superman but
you do like that world he did like Man
of Steel it's definitely worth checking
out and so yeah ma I probably score at
seven point five out of ten maybe
leaning towards an eight but also like
this some bits like with the second part
of the movie they've been so little
changed I've kind of watched those bits
over and over and oh yeah the Doomsday
fight makes sense now as well you do get
why in the original one you were like
why the [ __ ] has Lex Luthor set these
two up to fight each other
when he's going to release tomb state
who's going to kill him anyway and you
get bit like in this where there's like
a little countdown so when Superman was
meant to arrive or Batman was meant to
arrive with whoever won whichever one
died was going to show up to where Lex
was and if batman hadn't had have killed
superman doomsday wasn't going to be
released but if Superman had have killed
Batman and doomsday was going to be
released it's just little things like
that that flesh it out Ben Affleck
smashed it definitely the best Batman on
film so far and Henry Cavill yay you had
a lot more to do better performance and
Amy Adams killed it and gal gadot kill
there Jeremy Irons had a lot more to do
he was a very good Jena Malone and parts
kind of throw away to be honest I can
see why they cut it and it doesn't
really add that much more to the mood
but yeah everyone put in a good
performance really enjoyed the movie get
it on blu-ray yeah so thanks for
watching this video as well and here on
my thoughts so I might try and do an
extended review this as it's all kind of
new to me what happened is only the
second time I've seen the movie I saw
the movie in the cinnamon and obviously
seen this version this one is so much
better definitely check it out yeah and
if you liked this review please share it
please mate I'm dying for the likes I'm
dying for the views subscribe my channel
check out my game reviews and yet have a
Merry Merry Christmas take care mate
check out some of this Arkham Knight
footage or whatever and yet take a
priest